I'd like to sort of try to dig in and
understand what's the difference between
the online communities that are formed
and the platforms on which those
communities are formed sure really
important yes it is it is so for example
an office a good design for an office is
frequently you have
um you know the uh the commons which is
like the lunchroom or the Gathering area
then everybody else has a cave on the
border they can kind of retreat to cave
in the gums I love by the way I was
laughing internally about the Heat
versus work I think that's gonna stick
with me that's such an interesting way
to see Twitter yeah like is this heat or
is this is this thread
like because there's a lot of stuff
going on right
is it just heat are we doing some like
is it is there a directed thing that's
gonna be productive at the end of the
day that's right love is um Leverage
The Cave in the Commons is a really nice
uh so that has to do with the layout of
an office that's effective that's right
and uh so you can think of many kinds of
social networks
um as being on the cave in Commons
Continuum for example Twitter is just
all Commons the caves are just like
individual DMS or DM threads or whatever
but it's really basically just one
gigantic Global public Fight Club for
the most part right then you have for
love Club well some would love but
mostly fight or actually it's I love
aggressively that's all yeah I mean the
way I think I mean Twitter is like a
cross between
uh you know a a library and a civil war
you know it's something where you can
learn and but but you can also fight if
you choose to fight right
um yeah well I mean it's um uh because
of its the commons structure of it it's
a mechanism of virality of
anything yeah so you just describe the
kind of things that become viral yeah
meaning no no offense to liberians it's
like a library and Liberia Liberia was
racked by Civil War for for many years
right uh libraries is one of my favorite
sets uh for porn just kidding jokes I'm
learning is that's probably crossing the
line uh for the engineers working on
this humor module maybe take that down
yes
um gosh uh we're just talking about oh
yeah so continue going continue the
commons yeah so tutors are commons and
Facebook is like it's got all these
Warrens and stuff Facebook is very
difficult to reason about uh like
privacy on that and the reason is I
think it's easy to understand when
something is completely public like
Twitter or completely private like
signal and those are the only two modes
I think in which one can really operate
when something is quasi-private like
Facebook you have to just kind of assume
it's public because if if it's
interesting enough it'll go outside your
friend Network and it'll get
screenshotted or whatever and posted and
so you know Facebook is sort of sort of
forced into default public despite its
privacy settings uh you know for anybody
who says something interesting you know
if it's like uh you can figure out all
their dials and stuff like that but just
hard to understand unless it's totally
private or totally public right you have
to basically treat it if it's totally
public if it's not totally private okay
at least under a real name I'll come
back to pseudonym so you've got Twitter
that's that's total Commons Facebook
which is like a Warrens you know it's
like you know it's like rabbit worms or
like a ant colony where you don't know
where information is traveling then
you've got Reddit which has serve your
Global Reddit and then all the
subreddits that's a different model of
cave and Commons
I think one of the reasons it works is
that you have individual moderators
where something is totally off topic and
acceptable uh totally off topic and
unacceptable in this subreddit and
totally on topic and acceptable another
that's like kind of a you know a
precursor of the digital societies I
think that we're going to see that
actually have become physical societies
like lots and lots of subreddit like
things you know become fiscal societies
then you start going further into like
Discord where it's it's more full
feature than
um you know as you go Twitter Facebook
Reddit now you jump into Discord and
Discord is a bunch of individual
communities that are connected and you
can easily sort of jump between them
right and then you have slack and you
know yes you can use
um slack to go between different company
slacks but slack historically at least
I'm not sure what their current policy
is historically they discourage public
slacks so there it's mostly like you
have your main slack for your company
and then you sometimes may jump into
like uh let's say you've got a design
consultant or somebody like that you'll
jump into their slack but Discord is
you've got way more discords usually
that you jump into than slacks right